[Music]
I think liberals have a very hard time
understanding their role in creating the
market for Trump I think we have a view
of ourselves that has a bunch of blind
spots in it in terms of how we're
showing up I've gone all across the
country I've got a chance to go to West
Virginia the red parts of Indiana
Michigan even the red counties in
California I've gone to the border and
it gives you the chance to really kind
of see the world you know from the other
side as a liberal as a progressive one
of the things I think that we don't
understand and then we have a hard time
getting our heads wrapped around is we
often commit the same mistakes with
people in the red states that we accuse
conservatives of of committing for
instance if you only listen to NPR only
watch CNN and only read the New York
Times and say I know what's happening
then you're committing the same kind of
mistake as somebody who only reads on
the Wall Street Journal watches Fox News
and you know you know listen to Rush
Limbaugh on the radio which is not to
say that CNN is as far left as Fox is to
the right is to say that there's a
particular set of assumptions you're
being reinforced in particular set of
ideas and so you might assume then that
any rational person would be outraged by
what you're outraged by and even has the
same information that you have but
that's just not true we can sometimes
come across in ways that are offensive
to people who are in the red states and
who are conservative which shocks a lot
of liberals and I'm not offensive about
offending anybody I'm liberal I'm for
everybody
I believe in diversity I believe in
inclusion but it sounds the same way
when conservatives you know with a lot
of times you challenge conservatives
they say listen sometimes you guys sound
really racist oh my god how do you I'm
not rapper racist bone in my body York
nuts quit playing the race card on me
it's a the same basic thing listen to
what folks are saying I was into liberal
as they say they basically treat red
states the same way that colonizers
treat third-world countries
these are ignorant backwaters in the
south full of unwashed uneducated dumb
people and what we need to do is convert
them to our NPR religion and force-feed
them some kale so they can actually you
know rise to our level and once they rut
rise to our level then they'll be smart
enough to quit falling for dumb you know
tricks from their Republican masters and
you just like do you hear yourself do
you hear how you sound
nobody should follow anybody who thinks
that way about them just like most
people of color will never follow a lot
of the Republican Party as it talks
about people today because you don't
have any respect you don't understand
what you're talking about you're looking
down on us and then telling us that
we're deaf we don't vote for you know
we're dumb if we vote for you and the
same way in Reverse let me tell you the
kind of stuff liberals say all the time
that liberals think you know is
perfectly reasonable perfectly rational
and it's offensive and wrong
liberals say about conservatives
especially low-income white
conservatives who vote for Republicans
that these people are voting against
their own economic self-interest and
it's because they're you know not well
educated if they really understood what
was going on they never vote for these
people because they're voting against
their economic self-interest which is
stupid okay let's take that apart do you
know the white people who consistently
vote against our own
economic self-interest I'll tell you who
rich white liberals who vote for tax
increases to pay for programs their kids
will never use they're voting against
our economic self-interest we don't
think that makes them ignorant stupid
dupes we think that makes them awesome
that's the best thing about rich white
liberals is that they put their values
over their money their values are more
important than their money they don't
just care about money they care about
their values interesting huh so if you
put your values over your money you are
a noble person you're not an idiot
you're a noble person
well that low-income white guy who's
been voting for Republicans the whole
time will tell you well guess what I'm
putting my values over the money and I'm
telling you I don't want America's
government to go and rob some rich
family and take their money and bring it
over to my house and try to to bribe me
see I don't want America's government to
rob a rich family and use the money to
try to bribe me to be dependent on them
or anybody else
I don't want America's government to
take that money and undermine my
parenting choices if my kids are so
stupid they drop out of school
get on drugs and have a bunch of babies
I don't want the government to bail them
out let them learn a tough lesson but
that's a dumb way to live your life I'm
putting my values of Independence see
and common sense over whatever money the
government might be able to give me even
if it hurts me economically my values
are more important don't listen I would
disagree with that guy is that a great
strategy for building a middle class I
disagree but I wouldn't say the guy's
stupid I wouldn't I can disagree without
disrespecting see we don't have to agree
in fact the whole point of democracy is
you get to disagree dictatorship you
can't disagree
democracy you get to disagree that's
called freedom we like that that's good
but you don't have to disrespect and you
shouldn't disregard and these are the
kinds of mistakes
the Liberals make every day and you see
them on TV you hear them on the radio
you see them and if you are that red
state voter the one thing you know is
these people hold me in contempt they
look down on me they don't respect me
they understand me and now I can't vote
for them and that's a big part of what's
going on we we are not as good as we
think we are with this inclusion thing
with this understanding thing with this
empathy empathy thing a lot of us grew
up in neighborhoods or in circumstances
where you know the straight white male
had power and was abusing that power and
so we were formed in opposition to that
abuse of power and it's very hard for us
to actually be able to go on the other
side and say wait there may be some
situations in circumstances where maybe
we've got some power that we aren't
using fairly where we may be have come
to some assumptions or some conclusions
or have some prejudices that in some
circumstances we may be the ones who are
mistreating people or misunderstanding
people that's tough because when you've
been in that one down situation have
been mistreated for so long and you
still are being mistreated as a woman as
a person of color as LGBT and you're
still being triggered every day and
you're still being retry my ties every
day for somebody say yes and the truth
is messy there may be some situations
where it may be your reenacting some of
the very things that you would never
want and you may be showing some
prejudices even though you've been a
victim of prejudice your whole life
nobody was your that but that's a part
of what's happening and so without ever
relaxing our relentless fight for
justice for the people who have been
tried
left out we also have to start opening
our heart a little bit more in our ears
a little bit more for people who may now
newly be feeling left out either because
of their economic situation is stagnant
or declining or maybe because they just
don't fit in to the new arrangement the
way they used to and so they may have
some hurts they may have some out cheese
they may have some need for a hug and
some understanding and that's the next
level once what you do that will be fine
I believe we can peel off enough people
who may have voted for Trump remains it
may have stayed home that will be
alright but if we're not willing to look
in the mirror we're gonna end up where
we're headed and where we're headed very
bad I think the fundamental thing that I
would say to conservatives is that it
appears that what we used to call
conservatism has been replaced by
something else and it's a very sneaky
set of maneuvers has given us not true
conservatism but just anti liberalism
and that that is a fundamental problem a
conservative would defend America from
all enemies foreign and domestic
including any allegation that a foreign
power tried to mess with our democracy
we would expect our conservative friends
to be at the forefront of defending
American democracy but that is no longer
kosher because it would put you in bed
with the Liberals who are screaming
about Russian interference and so app
I'm not gonna defend in the country
because I got to stay anti-liberal I got
to be against the Liberals there are so
many conservative opportunities to make
real progress in unlikely communities
but for some reason they don't do it who
is more passionate about marriage and
adoption
then Republicans who are pro-family and
anti-abortion and lesbian and gay
couples who want to get married and
adopt kids so the two biggest champions
of marriage and adoption don't work
together because Republicans don't see
their ally they literally don't see that
the LGBT community is actually the one
community in America that whose marriage
rates are going up if the focus to have
you but all the rest of it and we
understand the need for adoption and
fighting for the Muslim community should
be embraced and celebrated by
conservatives because look at the work
ethic look at the load of divorce rate
look at the incredible premium on
entrepreneurship and education look at
the commitment to family and faith the
Muslim community is right picking for
conservatives but instead they're all
Qaeda they're all lumped into you know
the most negative category so I mean I
think that you know same with African
Americans the two strongest institutions
in the black community hip-hop and the
church churchgoers that's some
Republican stuff most Democrats are you
know on secular thing or spiritual but
not religious African Americans
incredibly strong churchgoers hip-hop
nobody is rapping about being on welfare
it's about entrepreneurship it's about
material access and you know that that's
very very consonant with republican
values but the only thing you hear about
black folks on a lot of the conservative
TV stuff it's all negative there's no
celebration of our religiosity our
entrepreneurial Drive there's just it's
just all look at these lazy criminals
well when you don't find a way to
connect with African Americans Muslims
the LGBT stuff on stuff you actually
agree on
that's when people start asking tough
questions about what is this
conservatism it seems to be marbled with
a lot of stuff that has nothing to do
with conservative ideas some anxieties
some maybe bigotries some antagonisms
maybe some white solidarity identity
politics or the white grievance politics
something else is in the batter then
just conservative ideas because
conservative ideas could play very well
you know across the the the the the
demographic spectrum and so I don't want
Republicans to stop being Republicans I
think I've never seen a bird fly with
only a left wing or only a right wing a
burden he needs to wings to fly I want
so you need conservatives you need
liberals but we need better
conservatives we conservatives who
really are willing to put the country
first who not only just say well I don't
I'm not you know prejudice I would never
well if you don't just say it then show
it do it you're concerned about what's
going on in Chicago and you want to say
oh look at those black people killing
each other no no those are Americans
dying in Chicago oh you know the police
are killing black people know police are
killing unarmed Americans American
police are killing unarmed Americans
show up go to the funerals talk to the
grandmas show how your conservative
ideas can help Jack Kemp did that I
haven't seen a Jack Kemp Republican and
since he died
oh so you asked the question what would
I say to concerns I would say stay
conservative I'm gonna stay liberal we
can constructively disagree and make the
country better I'm gonna try to make the
Democrats better but you've got to try
to make Republicans better it's not that
you're conservative is that you've now
become you've curdled into something
it's more anti-liberal than actually for
ideals and ideas that could appeal to
everybody and bring the country together
get back to that and we'll be better off
[Music]